you have access to your origin account
and you'd like to keep it that way then
you may want to be careful about
swapping out your PC hardware too much
in a short period of time and
benchmarking since I could get you
locked out EA has confirmed that there
is an issue with gamers getting locked
out of their origin platform after
changing up their hardware and running
performance tests multiple times guru3d
writer hilbert haig dawn found out he
locked himself out of battlefield
hardline after changing out graphics
card several times to see how they would
run comparatively origin sent him a
notification saying that too many
computers had accessed his accounts
version of hardline clearly
misinterpreting the new cards and
multiple benchmarking processes as
completely different machines he has
released a statement saying origin
authentication allows players to install
a game on up to five different species
every 24 hours players looking to
benchmark more than five hardware
configurations in one 24-hour period can
contact our customer support team who
can help it's worth mentioning that
steam has a similar five system limits
with their games but is unknown as to
whether valves platform encounters a
similar issue let me know down in that
comment box if you think this is a big
deal or not so bad we'll be keeping you
updated with all the latest news e bits
and pieces so stay tuned to gamespot
you